Впевнена, щаслива і успішна  -
такою бачить сучасну жінку
Катерина Левченко.
І вона робить усе можливе,
аби для багатьох українок це були не просто слова.
Кандидатка філософських наук
та докторка юридичних,
вона вже 20 років керує першим
і найпотужнішим в Україні жіночим
правозахисним центром «Ла Страда».
Ми багато робимо для того, щоб саме жінки
почували себе більш сильними.
На жаль, таких жінок не дуже багато
і дуже хотілося б, щоб ті,
хто сьогодні дійсно страждає від насильства,
зрозуміли, що вони не одні
і що цю ситуацію можна подолати,
якщо в собі знайти сили.
В кожній країні світу жінки зазнають
гендерної дискримінації,
психологічного чи фізичного насильства.
В Україні покАзники  не найгірші.
Однак передусім тому, що українки не звикли
заявляти в поліцію на кривдників.
А іноді жінки навіть не розпізнають утиски,
озвучує багаторічні спостереження Катерина.
Коли вони звертаються на національну гарячу лінію
і розповідають про проблеми, які у них є,
і потім консультанти допомагають їм зрозуміти,
що це є насильство в сім’ї, - вони дуже дивуються і
кажуть, що так було і в родині моїх батьків.
Так було й раніше.
І що, це правопорушення?
Під керівництвом Катерини
робота в офісі постійно кипить.
Тут проводять щорічні інформаційні кампанії,
щоб жертви почали говорити
про домашнє насильство, а не терпіли його.
Юристи працюють над наближенням
українського законодавства
до міжнародних стандартів у гендерному питанні. Невтомна
Невтомна Катерина Левченко для співробітників - взірець.
Людина, як Юлій Цезар,
яка може робити кілка справ одночасно
і в неї все виходить на високому рівні.
Я би дуже хотіла досягнути якихось там хоч
мінімальних вершин і бути схожою в цьому плані на неї.
Катерина Левченко, натомість,
найбільше пишається роботою співробітників
гарячої телефонної лінії.
Адже часто це перша інстанція,
до якої звертаєтья жінка, що зазнала насильства.
Зламані ребра, порізані кухонними приладдями
зап’ястя, жорстокі побиття.
Наталі страшно подумати, що ці знущання
її колишнього чоловіка могли б тривати досі.
Своїм спокоєм, а, може, й життям жінка завдячує
психологам і юристам «Ла Страда».
Я почала вільно дихати.
Ви розумієте, коли ти
йдеш вулицею,
ти йдеш з дитиною,
ти приходиш додому ввечері
і ти нічого не боїшся.
Це дуже круто, це реально круто.
Історія кожної врятованої від насильства жінки,
яких за 20 років головування організацією
назбиралося чимало, надихають Катерину.
Я розумію, як гарно
жити без насильства, коли один одного
підтримують, таке було у родині моїх батьків,
і таке є сьогодні в нашій родині з чоловіком
і з дітьми. І тому, це до речі спонукає мене
займатись такою проблемою,
як протидія насильс тва, тому що мені б дуже хотілось,
щоб таке щастя мали і інші.
На своєму шляху, або ж з італійської "ла страда",
Катерина зупинятися не збирається.
Вона вже була парламентаркою
та в громадській раді при МВС. А нещодавно її
обрали Уповноваженою Кабміну з гендерної політики.
Тож Катерина Левченко вже на рівні уряду зможе
продовжувати справу свого життя –
боротьбу за права жінок та гендерну рівність.